Resident Evil 6 barring a couple of
reviews a lot of people have all
over this game so I feel obligated to
give you my thoughts so let's talk about
this Resident Evil 6 and in Resident
Evil 6 there's actually a couple of
outbreaks that happen you now have three
campaigns well you get four campaigns
actually you beat the main three then
you get a fourth one it's kind of a
secret one you know it's one of those I
you're done with the game but you're not
there's another campaign I would almost
consider it spoiler is talking about the
fourth campaign so I'm not going to tell
you who's campaign it is mayor in this
review we'll talk about the three so
among these new zombie outbreaks I'm
still going to call them zombies
although at this point they're not
really zombies they're infected people
but they're intelligent you know they
can use machine guns and you pop their
heads and big vines grow out of it and
wave everywhere I mean stocks go up to
the sky and fee fie foe fum and all that
weird anyhow the three campaigns
you play in this game are Leon Kennedy
Chris Redfield and a new guy named Jake
Jake I forget his last name Jake but his
name's Jake and the three campaigns more
or less have different playstyles to
them I mean it's the same game when I
say different playstyles each campaign
has a unique quality to it that the
others don't have that being said is
still a third person shooter zombie game
the first campaign I'm going to touch on
is Chris Redfield because that was the
first one I played and more or less it's
Resident Evil 5 but it's Resident Evil 6
now it's more action-based you're a big
dude you get big guns you and your
partner go around you just waste the
out of zombies or rather infected
dudes you grow bean sprouts out of their
arms and heads and yes I say third
person action game because that's what
Resident Evil 6 is just like Resident
Evil 5 was sadly we have to come to
terms with the fact that Resident Evil
is no longer a survival horror game it's
now a third-person action game do I
think that's weird yeah Resident Evil
started the survival horror genre seeing
the franchise move away from that it's
just odd to me that being said it has
now the next campaign I played was
Jake's I heard Jake's campaign is
horrible because it's a hand-to-hand
melee combat against zombies that use
machine guns that sounded abysmal and I
wasn't looking forward to it that being
said I really liked his campaign
everyone more or less has melee attacks
but he has like straight-up he can power
up a punch and just make that zombie eat
and grab him by the feet throw them
into other zombies at first it
frustrates the hell out of you because
you're like how do I they're using
machine guns dick when you get it down
you
start to master it you can really wipe
out an entire room of these infected
dudes with just melee combat however
it's not all he does he does have
weapons just like every other campaign
has so you're not forced to use his
hand-to-hand combat you can use the
shotguns or the rifles or pistols or
whatever however the melee combat ends
up being really powerful and really
awesome and an effective way to clear
out an entire room of zombies when
they're all closing in on you you're
like oh boom I got my guns then you play
another campaign after his and you
missed the fact that you can just kick
the out of these zombies like oh I
miss my melee the third campaign is Leon
Kennedy and at first it does harken back
to Resident Evil 4 it has more of that
survival horror vibe you know it's
really dark you have a flashlight you're
going through these really dark menacing
rooms you know you're like yeah this is
taking it back to Resident Evil and Leon
fights zombies at first they don't grow
bean stalks and sprouts out of their
arms and necks they are the infected
walking undead zombies three stories
that take place at the same time I
actually really liked how they were all
crossing paths you play a campaign in a
couple chapters in like Chris Redfield
will run across Leon Kennedy and you're
like oh holy what's he doing here
can you play Leon's campaign you find
out what he was doing there hearken back
to Resident Evil - I like that about -
the people have bitched about the fact
that since the gameplay campaigns are
different the game suffers from really
not knowing what it is or what it wants
to be it's not like it's like diehard
trilogy for the PlayStation 1 it's not
like one campaign is a driving game and
other campaigns a shooter game and other
campaigns a third-person action game
they all play very similarly there are
just little things here and there that
make one different from the others
another gripe about the game is that
it's three smaller stories rather than
one big story like Resident Evil 6 is
trading one set of complications for the
other it does have smaller character
campaigns but you do get more
perspectives does it have its flaws hell
yeah it has its flaws is it annoying as
sometimes yes you bet but that's
kind of Resident Evil tradition at this
point I have never played a Resident
Evil game and not wanted to throw my
controller through a wall just rips
my head off and one frame before I can
even react I'm like well you need now
I'm dead yeah thanks game I felt that
Resident Evil 6 was an improvement from
5 first of all the AI you if you play
alone and I do because it's really hard
for me to find a friend who wants to
play Resident Evil at the exact same
time I want to play Resident Evil so
I'll end up playing the game alone in
which case the partner you have
I've gone along with you it's just the
computer AI and Resident Evil 5 it was
the dumbest AI I've ever seen in a game
I'm out of ammo no you unloaded an
entire clip into my back and didn't
shoot any zombies douche what did you
think was gonna happen this game they're
pretty self-sufficient you don't have to
micromanage them you don't have to give
them ammo they take care of their own
they hold their own I saw Mike my
partner with sniping zombies and hitting
zombies and killing them and I was like
good job you Alex really cool is you can
join other people's games online as the
enemies I got this little notifications
like so-and-so is joining your game as
an enemy now it was really intense it
was a hard zone so I was in game-mode
meets rage mode I was like what
douchebag wants to play this game to
keep me from beating in how miserable do
you have to be in life to try to ruin my
world then when I got past the zone and
calm down breathe counted to ten breathe
in through nose out through mouth
meditated a bit I was like you know what
that is one interesting feature I like
that I'll probably do that that sounds
like a lot of fun till then I just hated
the douche bag that killed me and this
game's a little more lenient on ammo I
felt Resident Evil 5 had survival-horror
ammo in an action game so you're running
low on ammo for the first half of the
game you're like I just want enough ammo
to beat a mission but my stupid AI
partner is just pissing ammo into the
wind and the rest of the ammo I'm just
trying to live on it was a situation I
didn't like this one's a little more
lenient on the ammo we're like alright
now we recognize it's an action game so
here's some action game ammo yeah more
ammo by the end and you know what to do
is you save it because you're still in
resident evil mode and by the end of the
game you're like I look at this
cornucopia of ammo I can just waste
anything you'll die a lot in this game
you'll get frustrated with this game
there are these moments where it's like
oh hit r1 but in the time it takes for
the signal to go from your eyes to your
brain to recognize that you have to hit
r1 and from your brain to your hands who
hit r1 then your hands back to your
brain you've already been chewed on in
your face you're dead they're like oh
yeah that just wasn't enough time for me
to react and hit r1 DIC those situations
are in the game but they're not as
prominent they don't happen as often as
I heard they would in the end the for
shorter missions that take place at the
exact same time offer the really cool
perspective so you get to see everyone's
missions and how they intertwine how
they work together that's really cool
but ultimately you do recognize the
stories smaller in length however I do
think resident
six is an improvement on five I enjoyed
it more than five if you like five
you'll love six if you didn't like five
you probably won't like 6 because 6 is
still an action game but has it been
on more than it should have been
on yeah you bet does it deserve a
4.5 out of 10
no I'll say you don't have to buy it at
full price wait till it takes a price
cut goes down to about 40 bucks buy it
enjoy it because you probably will just
accept the fact that resident evil as
survival-horror is gone it's in the past
it's probably not coming back so your
favorite Resident Evil game what is it
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you seen here and you
want to see more click right here to see
more